this is my longest relationship that's
good that's good that's good I've been
able to do him before the long
relationship why not but two years I get
um I'm just
I just gotta get not bored but yet bored
you mean because there is an excitement
as you know we've talked about a kalila
and I when you meet somebody for the
first time in that judicial [ __ ]
fantasy [ __ ] that you go through the
right mm-hmm and then six months goes by
and you're like I [ __ ] hate but I
never had that what's wrong with kalila
it's been like I want to be with her
yeah and but it's I mean uncharted
territory really to be honest with you I
think that's wonderful yeah I mean
you're not a relationship no no I'm not
you're done I think for now I mean I I
enjoy being you know I haven't been
single since I was five years old I've
always had some somebody since I was
five Oh like were you talking about with
your brother then no no I had a
boyfriend when I was five his name is
marco we were together until we were six
his family moved to you yeah so then I
had another boyfriend when I was six we
did I wasn't cheating on Marco yeah you
go first no there was no overlap we had
broken up we never really broke up but
he moved and so I I met a new guy yeah
because I changed missiles yeah because
I wasn't in kindergarten anymore so now
I had gone to first grade when I was six
and I met at Brian and he and I would
play Batman under the jungle gym so we
had our area where we were and yeah so
it's consistently since five years old
I've had a relation why going
you're saying that you you you don't
know what it's like to be by yourself
single oh yeah I've never been I never
know well since I was single when I was
four
what a while Wow it's been a while in a
good 44 years yeah when you're finally
you know oh it's great
I could sleep in the middle of the bed I
wish my body all the way to the middle
yeah
[Music]